good afternoon
before i begin let me just say two
things one
when this is all over i'll take
questions when we
finish the today's announcements but uh
let me begin by expressing my deep
sympathy
for the family of capital officer
um sicknick
who uh has died in the line of duty
our sympathies and our concerns go out
for to his family
and the people responsible should be
held accountable
and they will be but today
today i'm pleased to announce the latest
members of our
economic team with this with their
announcement
i'm proud to announce we have finished
naming our cabinet
saving the best for last year 24
outstanding
women and men who will get our country
moving again
and who are going to restore trust in
our government again and who
all of whom are ready on day one to do
their job
this is a cabinet that i promised you
and i fulfill that promise it looks
like america it taps into the full range
of talent
we have on our nation and we have
immense talent
it's a historic cabinet this will be the
first cabinet ever
that is evenly composed of as many women
as
men in the cabinet this will be the
first cabinet ever
with a majority of people of color
occupying
this cabinet and it has more than a
dozen history-making appointments
including
the first woman secretary of treasury
first african-american defense secretary
the first openly gay cabinet member and
the first
native american cabinet secretary we're
also on track
we named a record 50 high level
appointments that are subject to
president confirmation
more than any president ever elected has
done
we've done our job we've begun my my job
of naming these people it's my
expectation and hope
that the senate will now move to confirm
these nominees
promptly and fairly as especially the
case for the nominees of secretary of
state
defense treasury homeland security i
nominated them back in november given
what our country has been through the
last four years
the last few days given the threats and
the risks in this world
they should be confirmed as close to
january 20th
as possible there should be no vacancies
at state defense and treasury and
homeland security
and we will remain in this dark winter
pandemic
and with the economic crisis that's
deepening and we have no
time to lose with regard to the entire
team
consider the december jobs report
released today
the anxiety and fear of the women and
men out there
reminds me of when president obama and i
were sworn in during the great recession
of 2009 the december jobs we this
december jobs report
shows millions of americans are still
hurting
through no fault of their own we lost
another 140
000 jobs the first negative
jobs report since the height of the
pandemic in the spring
more people more people have just lost a
job
while many have been out of work for a
long time
and the ongoing gap between black latino
and black and latino unemployment
remains much too large that gap
and in many ways the jobs report is a
pandemic report
with the pandemic raging people are
losing work
and losing hope hospital industry
restaurant bars lost more than
270 excuse me 372
000 jobs state and local governments are
slashing jobs
20 000 local educators lost their jobs
just last month in the midst of this
pandemic
there are millions of people out of work
unable to pay the rent or the mortgage
they're waiting in line for hours and
to get mon get food from a food bank
think of this the united states of
america
people are lined up for miles on their
automobiles
waiting to get a meal to put on the
table to feed their family
and they're left staring at the ceiling
so many unable to sleep
worried will they have their health
insurance wondering if they'll be okay
the bottom line is the job report shows
we need to provide more immediate relief
for working families and businesses now
now not just to help them get
the other side of this painful crisis
but a larger purpose
to avoid a broader economic cost that
exists out there that will happen
due to long-term unemployment hunger
homelessness and business failings but
by acting
the vast majority of leading economists
suggest
that that's what we need to do to revive
the economy
in fact economic research confirms there
were conditions like the crisis today
especially with such low interest rates
taking immediate action even with
deficit finances going to help the
economy
long term and short term reduce scarring
in the workforce
increase growth and reduce our national
debt
burden failure to act will have the
opposite effect
i've said before the bipartisan covert
relief package passed in december
was a very important step but just a
down payment
next week i'll be here with you all
laying out the groundwork
for the next covet economic relief
package that meets the critical moment
of our economy and our country we face
at the moment
for example vaccines give us hope
but the rollout has been a travesty
this will be the greatest operational
challenge
the greatest operational challenge we
will ever face as a nation
we're going to need billions of dollars
to get the vaccines from a vial
into someone's arm the vaccination for
millions of americans
we're also going to need tens of
millions of dollars
to help reopen our schools and to open
them safely
state local tribal communities need tens
of billions of dollars to keep educators
police officers firefighters and other
first responders
and public health workers on the job we
need more
direct relief flowing to families
small businesses including finishing the
job of getting people that two thousand
dollars in relief
direct payment 600 is simply not enough
when you have to choose between paying
rent putting food on the table
keeping the lights on i also hope
the democratic control of the house and
senate will raise the odds
of prompt action on increasing the
minimum wage
i've long said that we need to reward
work not just wealth in this country
people in both parties now recognize
it's time to raise the minimum wage
so hard-working people earn at least 15
an hour minimum no one no one should
work as
millions are doing today 40 hours a week
at a job
and still live below the poverty line
they're entitled to at least the fifteen
dollars minimum wage
per hour folks
the big focus will also be on small
businesses
and how to correct the current
administration's failures to get relief
to main street small businesses
that are most in need mom and pop stores
are the backbone of the economy and
they're also as you all know
they're the glue that holds communities
together
and holds them together but today
more than one in four small businesses
are not open
at least four hundred thousand are
closed for good
as a month goes by a third of black
owned businesses
and more than a fifth of latino-owned
businesses and more than a quarter of
native american-owned businesses
have less than one month in reserves to
cover expenses
previous mods of economic previous
rounds of economic relief
last year helped millions of small
businesses stay afloat
and keep employees in the payroll but
there were clear problems
black and brown-owned small businesses
had less access to that relief
mom and pop shops were often the last in
line
while big well-connected businesses
jumped in front of the line
and got more relief and got it faster
and at every turn
this administration the trump
administration
has undermined accountability for every
tax dollar spent
weakening oversight firing inspector
generals
so it's no surprise an independent
watchdog found that
tens of thousands of ineligible
companies
receive relief they should not have
including from fraud and abuse
siphoning off support for their very
small
businesses that are the are that needed
so badly
but the good news is that the relief
package passed
last month provides additional aid to
small business and workers
but as i said from the beginning the
need to make sure that relief and future
relief reaches everyone who needs it
we need to do more these relief dollars
will start to flow
quickly potentially while the current
administration is still in office
and they may send out money that they
won't have any control over
but for what for what we have to control
need control over i want to be very
clear what my priorities are
for distributing this emergency age
swiftly and equitably
our focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no
fault of their own our priority will be
black latino asian and native
american-owned small businesses
women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
but we're going to make a concerted
effort to help small businesses in
low-income communities
in big cities small towns rural
communities that have face systemic
barriers to relief
think of the mom-and-pop owner with a
couple of employees
who can't pick up the phone and call a
banker who doesn't have a lawyer
an accountant to help them through this
complicated process
to know if they're even qualified or who
simply didn't know
where where this relief was available in
the first place
we went through this down when we were
trying to bring when we brought the
detroit back off his knees
and as we saw in this morning's job
report
restaurants bars and hospitality
industry have been slammed
by this virus we're going to direct
relief to those businesses and others
that have been
so badly hit hit the hardest
we owe them that support to help them
get
through the other side of this crisis
and i promise you we will investigate
and prosecute
waste and fraud in these programs so the
money goes to the companies that deserve
it
and will use it to help their employees
and their communities
when the president when my president
president obama asked me to handle
implement the recovery act
along with don who helped me a great
deal we invested more than 800 billion
dollars in our economy to help recover
rebuild in less than two-thirds of one
percent waste fraud or abuse
occurred we know how to do this we know
how important
predictability and clarity are to small
businesses
from day one this administration
work to ensure the small businesses and
financial institutions
in every community understand the rules
for these programs
the resources available to them where
they can turn for technical assistance
if they need it
we will have navigators who help guide
them through each step of this process
until the money they need is in their
bank account
until the lenders participate in these
programs you should move quickly without
delay
to begin extending relief but i
urge you not to to not disabuse
these funds not excuse me
not not to disperse these funds in the
same
inequitable way you have in the past
here's my commitment
in return we'll make our our
expectations
of you crystal clear the banks
so that you can quickly and equitably
deliver relief to the communities
that you serve unlike what's been
happening in many places
the bottom line is we're in the midst of
the most economic
unequal economic and jobs crisis in
modern history
congress needs to act as quickly as
possible on
all the issues i just laid out that's
how we can contain the pandemic
build back better with an economy that
works for all americans
and this is a team that's going to help
get that done
secretary of commerce i nominate
governor gina raimondo
of rhode island the daughter of working
class family
who knows what's like when her parents
factory job was shipped overseas
she never took her parents sacrifices
for granted
she always remembers where she came from
she became a successful entrepreneur who
created jobs on main street
and brought businesses back from the
edge she became a state treasurer who
invested in local communities and took
on financial predators
and today she's one of the most
effective forward-thinking governors in
the united states of america the first
woman ever to leave the oceans
lead the ocean state she created an
innovative
loan program that helped minority-owned
and women-owned businesses
access the capital they need but wasn't
always available to them
she's worked with employers to design
skill training programs
so the local workers would be equipped
to take the good paying jobs
in their own communities should put
rhode island on the path to achieving
100 percent renewable energy and should
be a key player in helping
position the united states as a global
leader in the 21st century clean energy
economy
and she knows what her fellow governors
democrats and republicans alike
are dealing with on the front lines of
the pandemic and economic crisis they're
facing
and how we can all partner together as
one nation to contain
kova 19 to build back better i'm honored
governor you're willing to join the
administration
and uh we're really looking forward to
working with you
for secretary labor i nominated a good
friend
and a stand-up guy marty walsh of boston
son of irish immigrants from his only
downside he's not
they're not from mayo they're from
galway um from galway
and moved to boston marty was born and
raised in dorchester
i know him tough as nails diagnosed with
cancer at age seven
beat it at age 11. joined the laborers
union
2223 at age 21
elected to the state legislature became
union president
and graduated from college at age 42.
he's now in his second term as a
successful mayor
of the iconic american city of boston
who always puts working people first
fighting for a fifteen dollar minimum
wage paid family leave
providing front-line workers with
emergency child care and protective
equipment they need
marty understands like i do that the
middle class built this country
and unions built the middle class
he sees how union workers have been
holding this country together during
this crisis
healthcare workers keeping our hospitals
safe clean and effective
and efficient i might add public service
workers
fighting against budget shortfalls to
keep communities afloat
port workers car haulers warehouse
workers folks
keeping our air and rail systems running
they're literally what's keeping us
going and they deserve a secretary of
labor
who knows how to build their power as
workers
who knows that when i say our future
will be made in america
it will be a future built by american
workers
a future with historic investments in
infrastructure clean energy
manufacturing
and so much more that's going to create
millions of good
paying jobs marty knows worker power
means not just protecting the right to
unionize
but encouraging unionization collective
bargaining
the fair labor standards act way back
didn't say
didn't just say you can have unions and
said the government should encourage
the formation of unions
it also means protecting pensions
ensuring workers safety
increasing the minimum wage ensuring
workers are paid
for the overtime they've earned like we
fought for in the obama bide
administration but this administration
has weakened
making sure that we have a trade policy
where for
every decision we make unions are at the
table
focused on winning good jobs for
american workers
this is one of the most important
departments to me i trust
mayor walls and i'm honored he accepted
but i also want to
say i did give serious consideration on
nominating my friend bernie sanders to
this position
i'm confident he could have done he
could have done a fantastic job
i can think of no more passionate
devoted ally to working people in this
country
but after tuesday's results in georgia
giving democratic control
to the united states senate and a thai
vote
bernie and i agreed that matter of fact
bernie said we can't put control of the
senate at risk
on the outcome of a special election
vermont
and he agreed we couldn't take that
chance
we also discussed how we'd work together
travel the country together helping
marty meeting with working
men and women who feel forgotten and
left behind in this economy
we agreed that we'll work closely on our
shared agenda of increasing worker power
and to protect the dignity of work for
all working people
i want to thank bernie for his continued
friendship and leadership
i look forward to us working together
along with marty
and he thinks i made a good choice
for administrator of the small business
administration i nominate
isabel guzman isabel grew up in
california working alongside her
dad in a small veterinary business that
he built
she devoted an early understanding and
developed an early understanding
of what small business means to their
employees
into the neighborhood they support and
to the families who dreams they
represent
she dedicated her career to creating
jobs to supporting entrepreneurs
as a senior official on the obama biden
small
business administration as director of
california's office of small
business and a small business advocate
she worked tirelessly to ensure that
everyone with an entrepreneurial spark
had a fair and equal shot at getting off
the ground and succeeding
the biden harris administration will be
locked in on helping small businesses
recover rebuild and remain the engines
of our economic
strength and as head of the sba
isabel will be leading a critical
mission not only to rescue small
business in crisis
but to provide the capital to
entrepreneurs across the country
so they can innovate create jobs and
help lead us into recovery i'm grateful
that she accepted the call to serve in
washington
for deputy commerce secretary nominate
i have to admit to you good loyal great
friend
don graves don is a long time entrusted
advisor
he was there at the treasury department
during the depths of the great recession
helping small businesses weather the
storm and stay afloat
when president obama asked me to lead
the effort to get detroit out of
bankruptcy and off its back
and on his feet again he said i could
take anyone in the administration
on my team to do it full-time so i went
to the treasury department
i tasked don to come over and work for
me
and work on it full-time it was the best
decision i ever made
in that effort i'm not sure how he
thinks about that but i think it was the
best decision i've ever made
and did a great job working with city
officials state officials
on its road to recovery and by the way
it's the little things
it's getting to know what's happening on
the ground
remember how we threw the issue about
the number of buses and lights
street lights and like it gets down to
the nitty gritty
of what has to be done we found out that
droid had a lot of qualified people but
during the
great recession almost everyone who knew
how to program
anything left so when we finally got it
back on its feet again we found out
there wasn't anybody left to know how to
turn on the street lights
literally run the sewer department so we
went out and we got an outfit to come in
and we said find us hike some high-tech
people they came back was it 53
55 people they all happen to be
women most were minority
none had more than a high school degree
and a quarter of them only had a ged
and i remember even our very liberal
friends we told them we were doing this
they said i'm not going to do this
well guess what in a 14 week was a 14
week
program they were taught how to program
they were taught how to do it all they
ended up putting the city back on its
every one of them left after that time
because he went to the graduation
the lowest starting salary of my
recollections correct was forty nine
thousand dollars
the highest 104 thousand dollars point
is give people a chance americans can do
anything given a shot
he also helped me lead our national
strategy to equip workers with the
skills they need
for good paying jobs in the 21st century
in healthcare
i.t clean energy advanced manufacturing
and so much more
he was there to help me launch the
national cancer moonshot
and marshall a full resource for the
federal government to help end cancer as
we know it
the cancer survivor himself diagnosed
and treated
while he was working on this for me don
knows about hope and he knows about
resilience
i'm grateful to him and his wonderful
family
for once again answering the call to
serve
i want to thank you all thank your
families
and i don't want to embarrass them
there's one guy up in the gallery here
tommy who's my buddy who is the son of
the governor
i thanks tommy for supporting mom doing
this
and to american people i know these
times are tough
but i want you to know that we're going
to get through this
help is on the way these people know
what they're about
they know what it's like may god bless
you all
and may god protect our troops now what
i'd like to do is
turn uh this over to the team starting
with our next secretary of labor marty
walsh
and after all said and done what i'll do
is i'll come back and answer some
questions
thank you marty the platform's yours pal
thank you good afternoon
good afternoon mr president-elect madam
vice president-elect
thank you for this chance to work for
the american people
i want to begin by thanking my amazing
family my wonderful husband andy
my daughter cece my son tommy who's here
in the balcony
thank you for your endless love and
support
we'll do this as a family
the mission of the commerce department
is a very simple one
to help spur good paying jobs
to empower entrepreneurs who innovate
and grow
to come together with working families
and american businesses to create new
opportunities
for all of us it's a simple
but vital mission
it's the same mission that's driven my
own life
and the path of my family across
generations
my grandfather was 14 years old when he
came to this country
he got on a boat by himself at 14 years
old from italy
he came to america in search of new
possibilities
he taught himself english late at night
in the providence public library
the library was open late at night
he started a family and the first
chapter
of our families new american story
my father was the son of another italian
immigrant
a butcher butcher who helped found
the meat cutters union in rhode island
which is now the ufcw local in rhode
island
and after serving in the navy and going
to college on the gi bill
my father went to work in manufacturing
spending most of his career at the
bulova watch factory
in providence
now i was the youngest of three kids
there were six of us including my
grandfather
all in a small house sharing one
bathroom
now we didn't have a lot but we had
everything that we needed
until one day my dad came home and he
said the factory was going to close
the jobs were going overseas
and so after 28 years of dedicated work
he was pushed unceremoniously
into early retirement in his mid 50s
i have to tell you it was a very
difficult time for my family
and like so many american families
across this country today we had to cut
back
cut back to make it through
but my mom my mom kept our family
together and we did get through
and i went on to college and i started
to chase my own dream of starting
business
and creating jobs for hard-working
people
because i knew exactly what those jobs
would mean
what those jobs would mean for families
who had fallen on hard times
for communities where the factory had
shut down
and for a state that needed a shot in
the arm to get
back on its feet
when i announced my run for governor
rhode island was in the midst of an
eight
month streak as the state
with the highest unemployment rate in
the nation
but over the last six years
we've worked hard we fought back
and we've grown our way back achieving a
record number of jobs
and the lowest unemployment rate in over
30 years
now we did that by bringing together our
workers
and businesses working together
coming together in common cause
we invested in our people in their
skills
their opportunities and their dreams
we helped new businesses launch and we
sparked others to hire and grow
responsibly
that's the same vision the same
faith in american workers
in american entrepreneurs that i see
in the build back better agenda
it's a vision for an inclusive recovery
that lifts up those who have been left
behind
it's a vision for a national effort that
provides skills
training and wrap-around supports to
get americans back to work
it's a vision for rebuilding american
manufacturing
and bringing back jobs to america from
overseas
and that's why i am ready to get to work
i am excited to get to work on a
national scale to help realize the
vision
of the president-elect and vice
president-elect
to help more hard-working families in
every community
write the next chapter of their own
american stories
so thank you thank you for this
opportunity
to serve the american people
thank you governor romano and i look
forward to working with you in my role
as well
uh mr president-elect madam president
vice president-elect
i want to thank you for the opportunity
to serve the american people
the word labor means everything to me as
you mentioned earlier mr vice pres mr
president-elect
my mother and father came to this
country as immigrants
from galway which is in ireland but from
a part of galway called kanamara
they brought with them their willing
hands their honest hearts
and hopes for the american dream but all
they needed
because my father joined the labors
union in boston was that opportunity
and that's why my parents were able to
raise my brother john and myself
with dignity and security in the
multi-ethnic
multi-racial working-class neighborhood
of dorchester
in the city of boston i followed my
father into that union
i learned what it took to turn an honest
day's work into an honest day's pay
i saw it fighting for good jobs good
benefits a safe workplace
does for the lives of hard-working men
and women in their families
and i fought for working people every
single day of my life since then
today we're at a crossroads in america
it's a time of great hardship working
people
holding the country together right now
i've seen it up close
as mayor of the city that i love boston
healthcare workers first responders
grocery store workers delivery drivers
postal workers sanitation workers
custodians
coming through for us under impossible
conditions
but this is this isn't just because the
covet crisis or the economic crisis
that threatens their well-being working
people have been struggling for a long
time
under the erosion of their rights in the
deep inequalities of race gender and
class
for the last four years they've been
under assault attacks on their rights
their livelihoods and the unions that
built the middle class
we are facing hard times but nobody's
tougher
than the american worker and now
now we have the opportunity to put power
back in the hands of working people all
across this country
and that is a good thing for our economy
and for our country
we can defend workers rights we can
strengthen collector bargaining
we can grow union membership we can
create
millions of good-paying jobs with
investments in infrastructure
clean energy and in high-tech
manufacturing
along with the workforce training to
help get those people into those good
jobs
this team the biden harris team has the
plans to make this happen
mr president-elect we spent many
memorable days together in my hometown
at a rally to support grocery store
workers fighting for their rights
and my inauguration as mayor and on a
day that i will never forget
at the boston marathon memorial where
you lifted up
our whole city spirits so i know that
from dorchester to scranton wilmington
to west virginia and all across this
great nation
your home in your heart or with the
working people
i look forward to working with you to
deliver good jobs
with dignity security prosperity and
purpose
to all american families and i look
forward to working
with this entire administration shoulder
to shoulder
with american workers to build back our
country better
thank you once again for this incredible
honor may god bless the american worker
and may god bless the united states of
america
good afternoon mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i am honored
and truly thankful for this opportunity
to serve america's small businesses
together with you and the exceptional
and diverse
team you're assembling i am eager to
build our economy back better in every
community
small business experience is personal to
me
i grew up in an entrepreneurial family
my father started his first veterinary
hospital when i was one years old
and i recall early childhood memories of
tagging along with him to the hospitals
to check on the animals
under his care as i grew older
i worked alongside my dad at the family
business and witnessed his dedication to
his clients
his employees in the community i saw him
spending endless hours wearing multiple
hats
tirelessly working to learn more and
grow the business
those memories have defined my career
and really
inspired my work still today along my
own path
i have partnered to start businesses and
i have helped entrepreneurs launch
and grow their firms i have advised a
startup
minority-owned bank and i have
co-founded a consulting firm
for small business contractors at the u
s small business administration
i was honored to help make a difference
on a national scale
i formed a deep passion for the sba's
work providing loans
investments contracts and counseling
to help entrepreneurs start and grow and
spur job creation
today as california's small business
advocate
i support the small businesses and
innovative startups of this fifth
largest economy
in the world focusing on ensuring the
economy works for everyone
as that's how we thrive together now
i'm honored to return to the sba at a
crossroads moment for small businesses
the dreams they embody the people they
lift up
and the communities they serve so many
small businesses across the country have
been devastated by the
pandemic and economic crisis a
disproportionate impact
has fallen as it often does on our
businesses owned by people of color
small businesses have had to adapt
quickly to survive
and chase down relief while facing
closures
drops in revenues shrinking cash flow
and increasing debt i know you believe
wholeheartedly mr president-elect and
madam vice president-elect
that all of our small businesses are
critical to our collective success
as a nation their american dreams
fuel our economy bring new ideas to
transform our lives for the better
and enliven every main street in america
and now more than ever our small
businesses need us
i share your commitment to help
strengthen this many small business
owners who have seen their dreams and
their livelihoods
impacted by covid19
and to create opportunities and instill
greater equity
in all of the new startups that will
lead us to recovery
i am excited to get to work with the
incredible
mission driven civil servants at the sba
to help america's small business owners
build better futures for their families
and their communities and i am grateful
for this opportunity
to serve thank you so much
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm honored and humbled to be here today
i first want to thank my family for
giving me
permission to once again serve the
american public
i've spent my career in government the
private sector
and non-profits finding ways to ensure
that economic opportunity
is inclusive and broad-based and as it
is for
all of us in our own ways it's personal
i come from a long line of small
business owners
including one who owned and operated the
only african-american owned
hotel in the mid to late 1800s just four
short blocks
from where the commerce department sits
today
but for too many people in this country
the chance to start
and grow a business to take their idea
into market
and sell all over the world remains
elusive all these years later
but we also know that government its
resources
and its experience and capable civil
servants can help level the playing
field
and empower people communities and our
economy to reach their full
potential mr president-elect i saw it
firsthand
when you and president obama prevented
another great depression
and helped us recover rebuild and put us
on the way to resurgence
i saw it in detroit where we were able
to provide the partnership to help
residents businesses and leaders get
their city back on the feed again
and as we traveled the country meeting
with local leaders
labor unions business leaders and
educators
i saw how you brought people together to
ensure american workers
were equipped and matched with the
skills for jobs in their own communities
that also strengthened the economic
competitiveness of our nation
above all you showed me how to do it the
right way
to understand that service isn't about
those who serve
but the people we serve to spend the
extra time to really understand what
they're going through
and to know they aren't looking for us
to solve everything but to understand
and help
make their lives better i felt that most
through the cancer
moonshot you launched deeply personal to
both our families
that gave the american people a renewed
sense of hope in what we can do
as a nation with governor raimondo
mayor walsh isabel and the entire
economic team
we will govern by that high standard
that you and the vice president-elect
continue to serve to show
to revive the economy through the
pandemic and build it back better
to advance racial equity equity across
the board and to meet the existential
threat
of climate change with american jobs and
ingenuity
with your leadership i know this
administration will provide the american
people the support
they need to thrive and the opportunity
to turn their hopes
into lives of dignity and the respect
they deserve
thank you again for the opportunity to
serve
one of the fundamental values that the
president-elect and i
share is a belief in the dignity
of work we both understand
that a job is so much more than just a
paycheck
it's about dignity and respect
joe learned that lesson from his father
and i learned it from my mother
my mother taught me in her words and in
her actions
that no matter how you earn a living
whether you're a caregiver or a truck
driver a grocery store clerk or a small
business owner every job
has inherent value and worth
and every worker everywhere
has a right to earn a living wage
work in safe and healthy conditions
and pursue a better life for themselves
and their family we also know
that right now the dignity of an honest
day's work
and the financial stability of a steady
income
are out of reach for millions of
americans
the december jobs report makes that very
clear
food banks as the president-elect has
said are being strained
trying to feed people who've had to
worry for the first time in their lives
about where they can find their next
meal
essential workers like the nurses joe
and i called over the holidays
continue to risk their own health and
the health of their families
for all of us small business owners
from restaurants to barber shops to dry
cleaners they're hurting
and let's be clear those who run
america's
small businesses they're not just
business leaders
they are civic leaders they are
community leaders
they are the ones who sponsor the little
league team
and scholarships for local kids and all
kinds of local causes and activities
they're the ones who are role models in
their communities
and we've got to do right by them so
first
and foremost as the president-elect has
said
we will provide more immediate relief
we must for working families and
businesses
now and even as we address our immediate
crises
even as we work to contain this pandemic
and open
our economy responsibly we must also do
what president-elect biden and i have
pledged to do
we must build our economy back better
so that lift up everyone no matter what
you do for a living
or where you live whether it's in a
small town a big city
or anywhere in between and that means
providing
access to capital for small business
owners the economic engines of our
neighborhoods
so that they can create the jobs that
are
in our communities and help our
communities thrive
it means making sure we're equipping
workers with the skills they need
for the jobs of the future and making
sure our entrepreneurs and businesses
continue to out innovate and out compete
the rest of the world and it means
protecting and expanding workers rights
by fighting for a higher minimum wage
and paid leave
safe and healthy workplaces and stronger
unions from working with unions as san
francisco's district attorney to helping
author the domestic workers bill of
rights in the united states senate
i can tell you from personal experience
that whether
it's the apprenticeships of the building
trades or the caregiving skills of home
health care workers
this is some of the most important work
being done in our country
the president-elect and i know that and
so does
this team we are announcing today
these are leaders and i've worked with
many of them who together with the rest
of our economic team
will help create millions of good paying
union jobs
and build an economy that is stronger
and fairer
for working people they are seasoned
public servants with track records
of not only standing up for workers and
unions
but creating and spurring innovation and
creating opportunities
for small business owners and like
president-elect biden and i
they will fight to honor the dignity
of work the president-elect and i share
a vision of america where opportunity is
within reach
for all the people where everyone
can see a better and a brighter future
for themselves
and for their children with the
leadership of these public servants
and our entire economic team we will get
to work
building that america less than two
weeks
from today thank you so very much mr
president-elect
thank you guys
well folks let me take some of your
questions
we'll have chances again this week to do
it
but uh let me yield
and you tell me who we're talking
mr president-elect while we have
been here as you've been announcing your
economic team
we've learned that house democrats are
currently planning planning to
introduce articles of impeachment
against president trump
as soon as monday at that point it'll be
just a little over
a week before the president leaves
office
do you believe this is a good idea look
i
i've thought for a long long time
that president trump wasn't fit to hold
the job that's why i ran
and my job now
in 12 days
god willing i'll be president united
states of america
and i'm focused on the urgency of
three immediate concerns one
the virus getting under control
getting the vaccine from a vial into
people's arms i think
the way it's being done now has been
been
very very sad number two we've had four
thousand deaths
four thousand deaths yesterday and
things continue to rise to escalate
that's my number one concern to get the
virus under control
we lost over 125 000 jobs
this last month and people are really
really really in desperate shape and so
i'm focused on the virus
the vaccine and economic growth
what the congress decides to do is
is for them to decide but i'm going to
have to and they're going to have to be
ready
to hit the ground running because when
kamal and i are sworn in we're going to
be introducing immediately
significant pieces of legislation to
deal with the virus
deal with the economy and uh and deal
with
economic growth so i'm we're going to do
our job and
the congress can decide how to proceed
with theirs
but if a democratic member of congress
were to call and ask for your advice
about whether they should proceed with
this what would you tell them
i tell them that's a decision for the
congress to make i'm focused on my job
and did you speak with house speaker
nancy pelosi before
this decision was made or is that a
conversation that's still
going to happen i'll be speaking with
nancy uh
and the democratic leadership this
afternoon as a matter of fact
about my agenda as well as whatever they
want to talk to me about
thanks
thank you mr president-elect thank you i
want to ask you about your agenda
in light of the jobs report that came
out today
you're going to be laying out the
principles of your plan
do you think that the need for in the
coveted relief bill is greater than you
anticipated
and what is the price tag that you're
looking at i've been told it could be
in the two to three trillion dollar
range and then as it relates to the
direct
cash payments you've talked about the
need for two thousand dollar checks
do you wanna see that in a senate
standalone bill
as a way to speed up the process or do
you think those
those direct cash payments should be
part of the package that you're going to
be proposing well we're going to be
proposing an entire package
and parts of that package are of equal
consequence to people
unemployment insurance being able to uh
continue with rent forbearance
uh the whole whole range of issues um
and uh so that's number one i we think
that they all have to be dealt with the
price tag
will be high but as i said made
scant reference to in my opening
comments
the overwhelming
consensus among the leading economists
left right and center
is that in order to keep the economy
from collapsing this year and getting
much much worse
we should be investing significant
amounts of money
right now to grow the economy
and that's a pretty wide consensus and
as you know moody's had done analysis of
what i originally had been talking about
and said that it was necessary to keep
the economy from going down
it would raise we'd create 18.6 million
jobs
create two trillion dollars more in
economic growth than
the other administration would this
outgoing administration
so it is necessary to spend the money
now
the answer is yes it will be in the
trillions of dollars
the entire package but it will be you
i'll be here
next thursday laying out in detail how
that package is going to go but the
basic
story is simple that if we don't act now
things are going to get much worse
and harder to get out of the hole later
so we have to invest now
secondly we're going to have to meet the
emergency needs of the american people
i mean literally i know you know this
can that
people are having trouble just putting
food in the table
just having to stay keep the payment of
their car maybe able to turn the lights
on
there's a dire dire need to act now
purely out of what is a humanitarian
need here at home
and thirdly we're going to in the third
stage of this
the whole story is we're going to have
to invest as i suggested throughout the
campaign
in infrastructure and health care and a
whole range of things
that are going to generate good paying
jobs
that will allow us to grow the economy
so that's a long answer to a short
question
which is that the idea of with interest
rates as low as they are with the fed
having had its power
sort of taken away in terms of what they
could do to help this administration
like last
it's important across the board every
major economist thinks we should be
investing in deficit spending
in order to generate economic growth and
i wanted to ask you about what took
place at the capitol this week
you served in the senate for 36 years
and importantly you were there in 1983
when there was an explosion in a senate
quarter you were there in 1998 when
two capitol police officers were were
shot you were there
during the anthrax attacks in 2001.
what kind of an investigation needs to
take place and what steps need to take
place to
improve this security of the capitol and
then secondly
how do you think uh the the people who
are involved
in in these uh in the storming of the
capital
how should they be treated by your
justice department should they be
treated as domestic terrorists
yes they should be treated as they're a
bunch of thugs insurrectionists
white supremacists anti-semites 6n
is not enough i mean come on you know
these shirts they're wearing
these are a bunch of thugs thugs and
they're terrorists domestic terrorists
and that'll be a judgment for the the
justice department to make as to what
the charges should be
but the fact is they should be
prosecuted they should be
prosecuted the difference here is this
had the active encouragement
of a city president of the united states
and the way in which the breakdown in
security occurred needs to be thoroughly
investigated i'm not going to prejudge
what it was but the idea the idea
that these people were able to just
march up the stairs
march in and do it in the way with we
had
there's a great debate i don't know the
answer great debate now
was as was the governor of maryland
correct when he said that i was ready to
send in the national guard i couldn't
get authorization
what happened it deserves a full-blown
investigation people be held accountable
and steps taken that something less
could never
happen again and the difference this
time is
everybody every nation has dealt every
democracy is dealt with
individual terrorist attacks
by groups that are in very targeted
the largest target was 911 and the
buildings
well right down to blowing up you know a
bomb going off in the capital when i was
there
two policemen but the idea that
thousands of people
thousands of people could be marching
up the steps of the united states
capital breaking windows breaking doors
forcing their way in stepping aside and
the photographs of
i don't know what the circumstances the
photograph would look like you had some
of the capitol police taking selfies
with these people
that has to be thoroughly investigated
the authorities responsible have to be
held accountable for the failures that
occurred and we have to make sure that
this could never
ever happen again the damage done to our
reputation
around the world by a president united
states
encouraging a mob a mob this reminded me
more of
city states i've visited
in the over the 100 countries i've gone
to and third
tin horn dictatorships it just cannot be
sustained
has to be immediately immediately
investigated
in depth and people have to be held
accountable and lastly do you think you
need to change any of the planning
for your inauguration as a result of
this
totally different entity is in charge of
the inauguration that was in charge of
protecting the capital the secret
service
i have great confidence in the secret
service i have great confidence and
their ability
to make sure that the the inauguration
goes off goes off safely and goes off uh
uh without a hitch so it's a different
so i have confidence in
what is going in in the planning that's
been underway before this
and continues with the secret services
lead agency
thank you thank you
president-elect biden vice
president-elect harris good to see you
both i want to pick up on something that
you just
said about president trump actively
encouraging the insurrection at the
capitol
given that given the perceived threat
that he poses
my question to you is not so much about
the role that congress should play in
impeachment but rather
should president trump in your
estimation remain in office
i didn't think look i've been saying
for now well over a year he is not
fit to serve he is not fit to serve
he's one of the most incompetent
presidents in the history of the united
states of america
and so the idea that i think he
shouldn't be out of office yesterday
is not the issue the question is
what happens with 14 days left to go or
13 days left to go
and i think that what
81 million people stood up and said it's
time for him to go
and the united states senate voted
93-6 to confirm
that we should be sworn in we were
we were duly elected so i think it's
important we get on with the business
getting him out of office the quickest
way that that will happen
is us being sworn in on the 20th what
action happens before or after that is a
judgment for the congress to make
but that's what i am looking forward to
him
leaving office i was told that on the
way up here
way over here that he indicated he
wasn't going to show up at the uh
at the inauguration one of the few
things he and i have ever agreed on
it's a good thing i'm not showing up
earlier you'd said that
if uh you'd hope that he would show up
only in the sense that it was valuable
to send a signal to the world about the
transfer of power
you've clearly changed your perspective
on that because he has
clearly demonstrated he's exceeded even
my worst notions about him
he's been an embarrassment to the
country
embarrassed us around the world not
worthy
not worthy to hold that office if we
were
six months out we should be moving
everything
to get him out of office and teaching
them again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took
to get him out of office but i am
focused now
on us taking control as president and
vice president
on the 20th and to get our agenda moving
as quickly as we can
thank you another question about holding
public officials uh to account and this
is about an issue that's no longer a
headline but is no less
significant and serious and it's about
the more than 600 children who were
orphaned under the trump administration
as a result of the family separation
policy along the border during the
campaign you said that practice
was criminal can you commit will you
commit to making sure that the trump
administration officials
responsible for that policy will be held
to account
i'll commit that our justice department
and our investigative
arms will make judgments about who
is responsible how they're responsible
and whether or not the conduct is
criminal
across the board but as i said yesterday
i am not going to tell the justice
department who they should prosecute and
who they should not
that's a judgment that will be made by
the attorney general of the united
states of america
not influenced by me but there will be
a thorough thorough investigation of
who's responsible
and whether or not the responsibility is
criminal
and if that is the concluded the
attorney general will make that judgment
i will not
intervene to tell him who he should or
shouldn't indict her if he shouldn't die
and lastly beyond the covet plan which
you've detailed what is your
what are your legislative priorities
you've talked about infrastructure
you've talked about introducing an
immigration bill
after january 20th you'll control
democrats rather will control the house
in the senate what do you do first
two different three different issues
there and that same question
one the commitments i made that i what i
would introduce
not necessarily we would move to but
introduce in the united states congress
first i will do
i will introduce an immigration bill
immediately and have it sent to the
appropriate committees to begin movement
i will in fact countermand
executive orders that the president has
in fact initiated
that are contrary to what i think is
either his authority and or
even if it's authority contrary to the
interest united states on environmental
issues and a whole range of other things
and thirdly i will immediately move
though
to the most urgent need of asking the
congress
to give me the financial wherewithal to
deal with the virus
to deal with the virus to be able to
move so that we have operation warp
speed
really working warp speed got
the the the vaccine to places
that were delivered but did not get them
from those vials into people's arms
and so it is a gigantic logistical
concern of how we do that i'm committed
to get 100 million shots in people's
arms in the first 100 days
i'm committed to insisting that on all
federal
jurisdictions any place i have control
as president
everyone will be mandated to wear a mask
an internet interstate transportation
as well as federal facilities and
thirdly
i'm committed to moving as rapidly as
possible
to get the vaccine to teachers and the
material
to children that can provide for the
safe opening of our schools
at the end of that beginning at the end
of that hundred days
they're the most urgent things we have
to do now
now immediately upon getting officers
there's going to be multiple things as
you well know because you're
a seasoned veteran of how this policy
how we work
and that is that there will be other
committees will be holding hearings on a
whole range of issues from
my positions on infrastructure what we
should be doing to generate
uh green economy how
and so on but in terms of the immediate
need to get
done not just introduced but to get done
voted on and get the money and resources
do it
it turns out that the most urgent need
is dealing with
the virus number one and economic relief
to
americans who through no fault of their
own are really getting battered
thank you
thank you mr president-elect and madam
vice president-elect i
want to follow up with respect to what
you just said about the
inauguration and that it's a good thing
that uh the president is not coming but
what about
the vice president mike pence welcome
i think it's important that um the
as much as we can stick to what have
been
the historical precedence of how in the
circumstance in which
an administration changes should be
maintained
and so if mike if the vice president
is welcome to come he'd be honored to
have him there
and uh and to move forward in the
transition
have you spoken to him at all no i
haven't
and you have called for unity
and healing in this country but after
the events
of wednesday does that make your job
easier
or harder i think it makes my job easier
quite frankly
i've had a number of my republican
colleagues former colleagues i've used
to serve in the senate for a long time
call me they are many of them are as
outraged and disappointed
and embarrassed and mortified by the
president's conduct as i am and
democrats are
and i think as i i have said from the
beginning and i have not changed my view
my overarching objective is to
unify this country we must
unify the country and i think that
you've heard me say this before and i
apologize for repeating myself
but understandably the questions are
repetitive and good i mean they're i'm
not being critical of the question
and that is that there's two ways people
are inspired
inspirational leaders and by terrible
leaders
by terrible leaders what this president
has done is rip the band-aid all the way
off
to let the country know who he is and
what he's about
and how thoroughly unfit for office he
is
and you see already a number of
republicans
i was so proud i know we're on opposite
sides i'll get criticized from some of
the people in my party for saying this
but i've worked very hard with and
against
the former the president the former soon
to be former majority leader mitch
mcconnell
i thought what he said on the floor of
the united states senate
was in fact the right thing to do
he stood up he's ashamed
i spoke with the guy i have enormous
respect for
enormous respect for and i ran against
him
mitt romney i spoke to mitt this morning
again
this is a man of enormous integrity
enormous integrity
who lives his faith there are so many
more but there's others
who should be ashamed of themselves but
they make
up a minority of the republican party
this isn't about republican democrat
anymore
this is about people who understand
what this country is about and the
things we have to agree on and move
together on
i i just think that if you look at it
speaking to some of my republican
colleagues and i've spoken to
a number of them over the last
last month since i've been since we've
been elected
through recently as the day in which
this god-awful debacle was taking place
up in the hill
and uh i think they understand that
they're going to have to we need a
republican party we need an opposition
that's principled and strong
i think you're going to see them going
through this idea of
what constitutes the republican party
and
they're here some of my college
republican colleagues talk about
how shameful it is of the way ted cruz
and others are dealing with this
how they're responsible as well for what
happened do you think some of them
should resign
should senator cruz or senator hawley
resign
i think they should be just flat beaten
the next time they run
i think the american public has a real
good clear look at who they are
they're part of the big lie the big lie
i was being reminded by
a friend of mine and maybe you were with
me i can't recall when
we're told that you know goebbels in the
great lie you keep repeating the lie
repeating the lie
well there was a print that when dresden
was bombed
firebombed there were 250 people
that were killed it was a 2 500 people
were killed
and gobble said no 25
000 or 250 000 were killed
and our papers printed that our paper is
printed
it's the big lie people will know it's
one thing for one man
one woman to repeat the lie over and
over and over again
by the way trump said that before he ran
if you say it enough i'm going to
convince you
i'll say it enough the press is bad the
press is bad the press is bad the press
is bad
if he's the only one saying that that's
one thing but the acolytes that follow
him
like crews and others they are as
responsible as he is
and so it's not about whether or not
they get impeached
it's about whether or not they help can
continue to hold power because
the disgust the american people have for
their actions there are decent people
out there
who actually believe these lies
because they've heard it again and again
i was with a friend of mine who's a
medical doctor
telling me that his neighbor said to him
he lives in another state
his neighbor's a good person said but
you know doc
this is true there's a lot of there's a
lot of a lot of
chicanery that went on in this election
i said tell me what well i just know
there was they say it is
they say it is this is a human condition
you say it and say it and say it and say
it
the degree to which it becomes corrosive
is in direct proportion of the number of
people who say it
and so it's interesting to me and i was
pleased to hear some of more prominent
republicans say to me
that ted cruz's of the world are as
responsible
in terms of people believing the lies
as not as responsible but similarly
responsible like
trump but they didn't say go to the
capitol
i'll be with you follow that's a
different story
thank you thank you thank you all very
very much appreciate it
thank you
can you guarantee that everybody can get
their second shot on time
on friday on thursday